how do we find the determinant of a 3x3
matrix we have seen how determinants of
one by one or a two by two matrices are
calculated if we have a three by three
matrix like this how do we find its
determinant it's really interesting
let's zoom out and find the determinant
of a now listen to this very carefully I
will be showing you one of the ways to
solve for the determinant we will look
at the other ways in another video okay
let's go
we find the determinant keeping the
first row as the reference here the
first element is a now the element a
will be multiplied with something
multiplied with what the element a is
the one one eighth element first row
first column it will be multiplied with
the determinant of whatever remains
after excluding the first row and the
first column we exclude the first row we
exclude the first column and what
remains is a set of these four elements
a will be multiplied with the
determinant of EF H I and we know how to
find the determinant of a 2 by 2 matrix
a is present in the first row and the
first column so we wrote the determinant
of whatever's left after excluding those
two wait it's not over yet then we
subtract the product of B with something
but with what its present in the first
row and the second column after
excluding them these four elements
remain we multiply B with the
determinant of D F G I and to this we
add the product of C with something now
why don't you guess what we will have
here
yes we exclude the first row and the
third column and these four elements
would remain we would multiplied with
the determinant of de gh this is the
formula for the determinant of a three
by three matrix a multiplied by this
determinant minus B multiplied by this
determinant plus C multiplied by this
determinant looks really difficult right
but it isn't if you remember what I told
you whatever element you take exclude
its row and it's column and multiply it
with the determinant of what remains
solving it further it can be written
like this this determinant will equal e
i- f h this will be the di minus FG and
this will be d h minus EG this is the
formula for the determinant of a 3x3
matrix first row plus minus plus and
multiply with respective determinants
let's try out an example with numbers
this is a three by three matrix a three
rows and three columns and we need to
find its determinant how do we calculate
its determinant let's keep the first row
as the reference one one and minus one
to start we need to multiply one with
some determinant the determinant that we
get after excluding this row and this
column it will be the determinant of
this four times zero minus three times
one from this we subtract the product of
this one with the respective determinant
the determinant of what remains after
excluding this row and this column two
times zero minus 3 times minus 2 the
only element of the first row that
remains is minus 1 we add the product of
minus 1 with something pause the video
and find out what we will have here
after excluding this row and this column
this is what remains its determinant
will equal 2 times 1 minus 4 times minus
2 yes the value of this will be the
determinant of a let's calculate it here
4 times 0 minus 3 times 1 will equal
minus 3 so we have 1 times minus 3 here
2 times 0 minus 3 times minus 2 is 6 so
we get minus 1 times 6 here and minus 1
times 10 here minus 3 minus 6 minus 10
will equal minus 19 the determinant of
this matrix a is minus 19 was this the
only way to solve for the determinant of
a 3x3 matrix probably not we will
continue this further in the coming
lessons